[Music]
Tekin World Tour 2019 and if you watch
this right now you already know what
time it is pick on Asia theater from
kbank out here in Bangkok Thailand and
its top 16 for this LCQ rip spag mark
man how y'all feeling man talk to me
it's time I'm feeling good I'm feeling
great it's time for some good Aztec oh
you're ready hell yeah ask him again I
don't think they heard you you can ask
them I'm ready for top 64 selfie kun oh
yeah we can hear that oh yeah
they've a quite making some noise yeah
but they'll get there I'm sure with this
top 16 row with the 60 players we got in
this bracket right now hey Paul
winterside Oh impacts down still still
living still breathing cannot rest easy
you still got a run-up and a tee but
still winners side oh yeah just the way
it feels man I'm getting déjà vu vibes
from tech your second masters man
somebody got a knock this dude in the
loose before it
oh my hey but we got below let's go a
lot of in witness and a lot of other
guys but first we have this match in
winners John ding versus musician Korea
vs. Korea we really talked about we got
to talk about it so there's a lot on the
line this lcj what does somebody get
from winning this tournament hey bud can
you get a spot to play tomorrow yes and
you can listen with chance with that
$250,000 prize pools about which is
crazy and you get guaranteed money for
actually qualifying anyway can you go
over before tomorrow so yeah you know
John thing has qualified for the past
two checker world towards this year has
not been his head he was second place in
points last year crazy this year not
qualifying I mean he has a huge amount
in the client so we were talking about
it just off stream that he didn't get to
play at any boxed river right he was
always you know just outside a night and
I didn't give him a lot of points so you
know can he do it here that's the
question we'll see he has his work cut
out for him we have Barack's dragons I
musician who has always been a
crowd-pleaser
any time we've seen him on the world
where he has a bit of that many events
but he is here at the LCQ trying to
I'll fight for that spot tomorrow
obviously we know he's gonna be thinking
Yoshimitsu who is judging gonna be picky
he's been using a number of characters
throughout the past myth we know about
lucky Chloe we know but and he looks
like he's locking Eddie
oh you music Julia earlier though it's
crazy yeah that was a weird one but he
is going with the Eddie er I musician
and Jonathan active oh that crazy
comebacks just to get into this round
right now so both them clutch in and out
playing on the top of their game today
it's gonna be exciting definitely some
momentum I actually paid I'm musician in
Korea internal with Eddie you know he
definitely knows the matchup mm-hm but
John thing he's gonna have to try and
stay in the mid range of possible if he
starts to pack - like and just play
really patiently you already know he's
gonna start healing man oh he is - to
wacky stuff - lets see I musician versus
John thing number one I think this is a
race to to hear top 16 action starting
off this to the winners side right now
these Pope's adding a prime use right
off the bat a second hit able to hit in
the relaxed position to me good wall
carry here you know what seems pretty
baby we go to the wall every time hey
dad cat for the perfect to kick it off
here in the theater tonight they've done
I musician on the for the other thing
mansion I don't think this has got it
I mean he's trying to prove a point on
here man that was my spot I deserve to
be in that's one yeah we should all nice
get the eBay gets a bottle up here
what's the big stuff oh I have never
seen any go to do that that was tight
maybe next week stops at the wall have
you go gets out a spinaroonie thought he
had the counter here what for an unable
to get anything out of it let's see what
happens that one it feed about of relax
oh it's been too it's spinning music to
my eyes beautiful look at it right now
I've used a shot two straight rounds he
is on fire today if you haven't played
it before as well I mean he's someone
else it's not most likely gonna be you
have so many setups such a wacky place
thought with yoshimitsu these guys have
played each other before the mustard
yeah but I mean how much bright I mean
this is definitely been grinding the
game is always in Jordan recently at the
invitational Ryan and I gave us the best
place in the world that's a great thing
about you know I'm using [ __ ] he kind of
really forces people to play his style
to come towards him and he's really
controlling the pace of this matchup at
least right now don't think having an
opportunity to see what he does with it
sure sword gets put away here yep time
winding down here though 14 seconds on
the clock now helicopter time huh goes
the unbreakable three half the duck
leaves jumping in rage seven six seven
o'clock there's no time he's gonna have
to get to the chopper Wow now with the
Darwin in first game four I'm musician
recent rounds man three straight rounds
are we gonna see a character switch what
did he do did he go to stage two late
that was so fast Chloe are we gonna see
the Chloe he's thinking about it or he's
gonna go that Jules
no he's Eddie Gordo yeah so he now gets
the opportunity doesn't change stage is
going to stick it with the wall stage
which I agree with don't want to let my
musician not run away from you it has a
very unique play style but this is it
man if you lose this hair he's gonna be
in the loser bracket not where you want
to be whenever this mess of course gonna
be in prime position to be able to
qualify and there's not that much
matches left we're at the top 16
all right to the dojo we go there we go
thank you with Eddie here now there were
a couple times in that last match where
John they managed to get into a relaxed
mix-up it was a pill 50/50 but I'm using
guess correctly if Johnny can actually
get the guesses right yeah we could see
a completely different game i scott up
with the tech roll catch there with them
a block full but rewind your follow up
here see what he does that's the wall
yep here's the mix-up what's he gonna go
for goes for the mid option but just
like that I've musician turning it
around yeah that spin has been so useful
in this matchup to get out of those
mix-ups that time John doing not check
Roy getting caught in the corner go
check again Hannah stay down stay down I
mean she did pretty seized up he knew it
yeah that's the big stuff too because
you know if he does get up he's gonna go
for the quick of blockable this time
knowing his opponents to say there goes
for the quick low kick yeah yeah great
adaptation with both players although
what it could have done for
and again Dundee displayed very
cautiously looking for this opportunity
for an opening big boot to the back into
the dry double town fit yes sore tooth
no go he was greedy there he thought he
was gonna get up oh my god I know
terrifying
John dig the hope stays alive yes on the
board finally and that's an indication
that that he has paid off in him who he
knows somebody's set up Faison to do she
just stayed the floor that didn't deal
with anything
Oh again he was holding down there got
him ethereals safe look at this he is so
cautious in the way he's approaching
this I mean he has the positioning but
he's just so scared to go up it you have
two against side musician though cuz
he's so unpredictable right he's gonna
spin away from you you can't just run
into like a running attack yeah but now
puts himself into rage and that's so
cheap so cheap you know what let me get
an extra advantage here I'm losing let
me get a little comeback yeah
the good thing is that Johnny's also
been getting the live feed of the star
they've got this time but the life is
deftly hope so because he just lost a
patient
yeah faxes mice and the damage they're
off their clothes whoa
oh you flashed it between dinos then
there is a gap in between that attack
3/4 yep against Pinta range Oh put your
ducks underneath the high so all the
power wow that was beautiful
Don dig with the comeback they're tying
it up now one game apiece how often do
we see that power crush not now often
and I'll use it at the right time here
we go final match and we're on an
infinite stage oh we got the Korean
classic we are in a stage with no walls
it's gonna come down to pure movement
and spacing between these two it's tough
to call cuz you got to remember
yoshimitsu still has so many tricks so
many traps that work in the open yeah
whether you stay on the ground whether
you tak roll there's gonna be a kind of
a test of wills so to speak yeah just
one bind this though you won't mind
having infinite anybody go that way
talking about how I musician continually
like to pick this infinite stage yeah
but again Eddie specifically that might
be a hard sell right maybe it's us Eddie
and Lisa yeah maybe Safina as well
we'll see it's gonna come down to life
please as well right yeah I'm just gonna
have to change behavior based on who's
winning in the live gage department
right now I said I even oh yeah this
apology is so annoying with the run away
on this page do you want to yeah he's so
evasive with just his ability to you
know the manual back then then he has or
the site the site step attack right
there
[Music]
second hit oh my God look at that first
around here for jut ding who has tied it
up now yeah look at the defense of John
Diego I know everything working out in
his favor here yeah and I know a lot of
back to roots or why are you trying to
open up jumping at the moment that's the
thing when he goes into back to the
starts to heal himself you have you know
you have your hash if you are late if
you have to take action
yes that was that was what was so
important I am I'm actually the one who
picked the Wallace name I should've done
this [ __ ] attack nice with punish
there from my musician now continue the
pressure he does have a slight light
seat here but now into the ring looking
at natural combo ten-second now if this
is where the healing is gonna be coming
huge back to time while oh my god Oh
from John dig with three seconds on the
clock is that point for him now yeah
again it's tied up just so you guys know
the score you should be updating but
follow up here yeah gets it catches it
gets the screw
that way what's the big Sun that's the
lasers makeup just goes for the sidewall
does one a four-foot Tech trap
I see knew that there was something up
there he had the Billy Goat from
handstand position into the power front
or in the air though yeah put it off all
wow just a little bit shortened range
there yeah because he was so deep to his
side here what's the mix-up you not
sidestepping this Eddie oh my gosh I'm
just staying alive you're two rounds to
one yeah John dick has been paid so
patients so much in this match to put
right there finally lots of patients I
was in full time to get the full watch
Wow oh my goodness you top to dry
musician here Rach available this is the
stay on the winter side of the row we're
going to a final final round of course
we are
it all comes out to this who is gonna
get your top eight winners so much to
play for again you have to adjust the
combos and see goes for the back to four
this time
what's the mix-up gets up with the low
yeah I like to relax their patio key for
jogging big league Oh traded blows look
at this on you hold likely but he has
great so you cannot count about what an
adjustment there on the fly from judging
moving on down bad in the winter side of
the bracket my man I'm musician he's
going to the loser's bracket it's just
gonna be even more danger for anybody
that's gonna be coming across his path
there's a lot of sharks women down there
for both these players who had really
good performances today up until now
really good set yeah yeah what a way to
solve the top 16 daunting that you
obviously so dreaming with as that bet
secures you hit my top eating fling
today oh man what a tummy time yeah oh
my gosh I just saw the next match for an
talent book going up against Pakistan's
genuine gaming a teeth but one man it's
been the story of the year you know the
Pakistani girl coming over here and I
was talking to our slob because you know
he would write now
they love it there's no there yeah there
he is
on screen book the local hero man isn't
winners as well so you're doing good
from sofa like I was saying you know
octopus our son who would you pick as
another player to get sponsored for this
world so he goes look I've played
Channel I've played me I've played all
these guys around the world and octave
bar is a different level that's what he
said and then of course he proved it
when he went to that moment in Tokyo it
looks very simple for him but I mean he
tell you something yeah tell us that you
might not know so do you know how do you
and I made the joke about about octave
but saying to know be you know is that
how you got that's actually what you
said because he was scared to fight no
because nobody's done so well that's pox
on before but when he beat him he was
like that it yeah my artist he's a very
quiet man because his English isn't that
good yeah just not confident English
well easily get there he's definitely
like his game do it all the talking for
sure he has done very well for himself
this year so far yeah in this bracket
today he's actually had some pretty
close calls getting it to this point
yeah but it's slowly starting to feel
like he's coming into his own he's
getting that confidence once again yeah
and just like Tokyo Tekkit masters I
just have that feeling of like if
somebody if two people don't step up and
eliminate him before he gets to winners
finals it feels like it's gonna be a
daunting task of running running into
sense for sure that's the question right
now right this is the LCQ
he's like the heavy favorite I feel that
a lot people thinking
take this entire LCQ and he almost had a
chance to make it in here without the
LCQ right he just didn't go to crema
catalana so now it's this chance but
he's going up against book here it's
time man he's got the hometown crowd
behind him right yeah yeah about this
match these bookies not a stranger -
he's been playing in slaw he's been kind
of in the character crisis deciding
which character he's gonna use that he'd
met people as well he was big long he's
been using geese [ __ ] man I mean for
the longest time I've seen him playing
gentlemen
yes Jin only the good thing about that
though is that it's gonna make it more
prepared for this match yeah definitely
has been doing these bits you know we
got some update up the loser side of the
bracket guys go ahead and talk about it
ooh the cha a heavy favorite in this LCQ
I I mean a lot of people who had their
eyes on him eliminated by mogul Korea
stepping in they go put putting into
that and then hero on the other side one
I guess that means that a teeth and now
hero are the last remaining players off
to a no cost him I'm not sure what
happened to cost him as well as he out
because I know he was in the loser
person loser secured yet but here it did
eliminate fighting spirit or fighting
spirit out of the tournament as well
okay but here we go thailand vs pakistan
book versus a tea but this is a big
match this is a match I feel like
whoever wins this could end up winning
the whole thing oh yeah pusher yeah
and it's gonna be the jin kazama for
book hmm I like it
and we're taking it's a Howard estate
yeah I mean the damage level when we
have seen this match up before it's been
mostly in a fume is failure because that
Ford for you can jump over it and that
kind of mood gets neutralizing his match
up in a way I've got your hair you
really need to pick your shots yeah I
don't feel like book is the fork or
chendo you know I think that's what he
really has a bunch of and since see the
boom wall broken there we go
go against the grain
here let's see oh what a pair he had
ready for some of them exactly I was
looking for for book how he feels how he
deals with this board board for neutral
how he deals with some of these very
very threatening options that Akuma has
to react they go from Paris attacks get
it behind book here and I'm gonna talk
about this can't be colored and I
believe was probably one of the first
spots where really saw the pen Sunday
coming to the the tournament scene it
really start wrecking everybody then
again it told you Tekken master yes yes
people have been studying character yeah
obviously so they're both down for the
10 20 20 min block a logbook wall
carried on a good set of it sort he has
a Barbie its record though now could
still be read a just good let's go book
the park backs and the golden he's
totally prepared in the crowd his hero
managed on the field is that that's
creepy clock of authority well that that
we got to talk about it's a Peterbilt
being much slower that is a bigger
mistake than exactly a great point gonna
have to be careful I mean he he cannot
make those kind of mistakes especially
if he needs that damage output to work
even harder now to get these ground
oops gotta stay sharp here
I live with a big life he's using that
for for now he's kind of trying to maybe
foursome to jump keep trying to back up
perfect his own nothing get it go very
far heading the round get the round
round three duckie put good stuff as a
barmy its work with going into the next
round can utilize it glad you mention
that earlier to write the fort for right
now is controlling so much I mean it's
horse you can see if you have to go
through the air and running trying to
get another approach yeah look at that
using the calm with this time able to
catch it and get some decent damage here
and positioning that's the fourth EPS
closer to the wall but book right now
fighting back to the other side
yeah chapter on the deeper flavor that
definitely shows I just thought his hope
work here man yo this is good oh down
for finally gets to connect this time
there's a fork or not a counter at this
time though the quartz close oh he's
fishing for that down - he wants it yeah
it was right time to do it like a matter
that could be the down to guess right
old players here get support for again
[Applause]
[Applause]
Podcast game number one I almost bit my
pen you can really tell book has done
his homework the defense Akuma defense
look he's so quick he did it run into a
single down - it was entrapment is the
confidence it lives will said that he's
using yeah he is he is actually putting
in work here he's forcing a reaction out
of a teef that we haven't really seen
him he was able to control matchups in
previous treatments that we've seen at
least on stream but right now that was
full control for yellow floral control
look in the downfalls floating the demon
flip you know keeping them out with that
with forward for constant adaptations
that book is playing really well can
octave bring it back though happens
conference and patients do is the big
thing
exactly confidence in just having that
split second where you don't hesitate
where you know exactly what you're doing
in the matchup that goes a long way
right now
it's a big jump in and this could change
Dixie boy for now over the board for
starting is changing it up now may be a
team pinky or liberties here and I
offensively yeah it definitely started
off a lot more effective but still gonna
help you catch up in this round
yeah then neutralizes the mix-up as well
you don't get you know you get damaged
you don't get any mix ups very very good
option
that's the thing he's gonna have to be
so careful to wait for more and more oh
my gosh here we go push the ball he
dropped the combo opportunity there he
had it just unfortunate there guys hey
funk is another jab out the air the
reactions are on point right now man
he's got a sailboat that's a train
reaction manly he's so consistent when
this entire set yeah working on building
that first meter gonna have to be
careful he's been using a lot of that
for Ford for book hasn't really been
using the ferry again to deal with it
bruised but do you know he hasn't you
know he got those well I think he's
using it a lot because you have been
ducking those downpours yeah at all I
just that might be nice have you the
author with a good answer back to you
around strike finishes oh that was the
first down to that he was able to land
the set so far yeah he's already trying
to rewrite that first would it be like
you know I gave you that one let me get
back if this mentality it's like it's
adjusting to book time right he's took a
little second to learn it yep and I
seems to have a better handle on it
but that's where it's really scared
what's a good was in full control
there's like almost no way out
is working again oh what's happening
here let's see what he does
oh well here we go Potter stuff little
bit late you shall try yeah using the
demon pom actually piece the jab option
to float so it's a very good option yeah
that's the prompt it's like yes do it
early he has to commit yes to know that
there's gonna be a reaction yeah if book
let him land you might have been able to
get a hit yeah but now cooking like
sidestepping hop kick or something right
yeah Oh actually no because it's got
really got a really good recovery man
that even pump yeah but definitely has
to do something he'll get a big
something in his favor yes that might be
it
here we go ha this is gonna hurt against
the wall - yeah you had to do it here's
hoping for a jump away or something
didn't a teeth but three year round
straight to tie it up one game apiece
what a statement here I mean it's like
that first match it even happen yeah but
now look how the option you just set
change the stage oh I'm guessing we're
gonna go to an infinite H a or maybe
Howard estate again who knows man
whatever you want whatever he's mostly a
B but yeah let the mass read a little
bit the Jin's been Toby no right man
it's been a real issue
yeah and he played very sharp the first
game second game I think be like a
teapot he just land more handsome when
Akuma hits you and a teapot control of
it so where's he gonna go he had the
opportunity to change stage for a
mission but dojo keeping a simple final
match here thailand vs pakistan this is
for winter side toffee there is a lot on
the line
mmm-hmm is it gonna be a teapot from
pakistan or is it gonna be thailand very
own book we're about to find out what
this final match he had the crowd on his
side you ain't got the headphones on you
they can have sometimes that power up is
what you need you gotta hear the people
right yeah Mishima dojo final game here
to stay on the winner side of the
bracket and the lesbian cruise rocket
let's go round opening
hopefully like this mid-range poke game
with the moon and jinns pokey very
strong to believe it seemed odd but come
on get down black or kind of a low poke
at all leave a couple down court so
that's it so they can get punished bite
down to write like you give me
interrupting and punish get the first
one no floppy yeah yeah got the bubble
that's big though cuz you know he writer
that he lost three straight rounds yes
so finally fighting back here some
momentum head Wow go clean hit like
fuzzy duck egg throwing the Perry in
there everything thought of trying to
find his way in defense holding a paper
book nice positioning here center stage
it's crazy the way he's using that floor
for before he's kind of just snapping
his leg like a whip don't run into it
he's trying to pay something out they
both are
[Music]
set point book down to versus electric
with hook fist which one is better this
is for a spot in top eight winners one
round away book and he still has to beat
her though she chopped it he's bad he's
nervous the crowd all buddy laughs big
down right here walled right there yes
you have another opportunity for damage
here nose for the demon flip mix-up
smart defense different book on the
ground he could've got guaranteed hit
that but did it go for it he had the
opportunity but that's okay for book he
spent a barmy so now he's a true yeah
very far away from another one gotta
close out this once he does get that
meaner back uncharacteristic drops
revoke head count even flip he did it go
for the chap stuck without board what
crowd coming alive
nice any she's gonna finish it he has to
do it now cook hot with the life lead
the downpour from downtown this time the
building that meters you have to be very
careful nice put it good lord it you
could have had the campaign nice defense
what's he put here oh man cares about me
- yeah he's gonna hit our next dog oh oh
here we go
party time uh-oh whose party is it oh my
god this is dangerous this is really
dangerous
let's he's got the one bar here looks
back is to the wall
in the bag 14 thank you what's the cuff
oh I don't know
is that gonna get the lightning you're
not gonna kill I don't think they won't
kill and he has advantage and look at
the time the deep but no time you better
make the noise right now oh my god oh
yeah take it to the wolf just like that
it's gonna go in try to fight back here
he's gonna be close to getting a meter -
this is where it's gonna start to get
hairy but right now he doesn't have that
much light no cool here oh here we go
talons hook taking it to a final final
round
what hand stuff here man Wow and so many
uncharacteristic combo dramatique but in
that set but that's what it is man what
is in that that clutch situation we
haven't seen octave go to that many
international talking book has been all
over the world
then he if T must not have too many
opportunities be able to play on a stage
like this dude you ever seen arena like
Tokyo second masters had nothing wrong
to set up Rea down right that it's a
completely different environment than
what he's used to and even on books in
right OB well characteristic drops for
him yeah even as difficult as the county
had for it for combo isn't this in this
season I mean he's been lights out for
it for the most part some really big
ones big drops at the end of the last
game but that's gotta do wonders for his
conference being able to win sometimes a
sloppy match like that you pull out the
win that's gonna do wonders for your
common is doing this top eight yeah oh
man look what's coming up next this is
more winner site action to see who's
gonna get into our topic winter sighs
right now we have from Japan liquid
again right margin Obama needs a raise
game and another one of the Pakistani
players we have we have faint below yeah
now fight for long you know the great
thing about him is that lot of people
don't recognize him as one of the best
players in Pakistan I think he is but
you know the great thing about him is
how good he is internally always
performs no matter what what about it is
he will perform
he loves that stage he loves to be on
stream all that kind of stuff but you
know recently in Jordan he went eight
and one in the round-robin you know only
losing to Osan versus me you know I
mission arsalan he beat all those guys
so this guy's really good when it comes
to tournament play that's his strength I
thought okay yeah the big question mark
for him recently has been character
selection right we seen today and
there's LCQ is been actually focusing
mostly on Akuma well he's been focused
on looking for the past few months but
you know Brian was his main character he
said he will bring you out if he has to
and okay what I'm thinking about that is
that if Gann body sees Akuma then maybe
you have to go see a shonali eliminates
cost of Mir from the Turnham a Pakistan
best bucks on much destiny it out also
8k eliminated be kun so a case alive in
asan Ali also still alive in the loser's
bracket we might be able to see them in
a bit but right now let's focus on this
winner's bracket match guys any bonds
any thoughts but let's ask Obama his
spots who do you think I think he's been
grinding Akuma he's been grinding
against keys he's been practicing a lot
of these matches that in the past few
months have been giving him a lot of
issues yeah I really took advantage the
past three to five we were like I feel
like a lot I think I've done and a lot
of the [ __ ] the Japanese baseball have
trauma from when our salon went over
there and banged everyone up so I feel
like him going up against a Pakistani
player he's gonna be it's gonna be free
for for below it was because of the AC
was too cold
new jacket a coffee but either way he
law from Pakistan going up against one
of the new generation wonder kids from
Japan man we screw up we first so again
in Tekken Tag 2 at Evo right now that
run we've got second place I've not
fourteen years old it was two years old
I think it's bad
ok ok so that's your kid come on man
that would be the boy well here we go
they're ready for it
Pakistan invested Japan yeah and I can
tell you man especially with his
attitude because that JP community we
especially with how nationalistic be
alright with especially with this game
right they don't express it very often
but I'm telling you they talk about that
stuff yeah I mean that community invest
a lot of Hope in this kid and when he
feels like he lets them down by not
qualifying even though he's you know he
started late
he definitely let that weigh on him and
he is definitely coming into this trying
that helps them to get better yeah have
you go sure he forget those legs crack
down for one freshman then again the
pinpoint uppercut forget yeah trade more
the punish goes for the doctor the easy
knocked up over the one two and it's
pretty good on get inside that he got
infinite edge because Shaheen gets huge
damage in the open anyway but utilize
that big damage out Cooper will get with
the wall in the traps as well you gotta
remember yes good know cuz I mean oh
here we go gets the punishment
jab into the follow-up he's not gonna
get the kill but he's gonna get a good
mix up there it is so okey right now
belong with the first round here over
again had the loss Romania Pakistani in
the winner's bracket Wow great point
big chunks I think a lot of players knew
that coming into here that they're gonna
have to fight against an army of
Pakistani players right yeah and I mean
I think if any of the players out there
were smart they would know to study and
fight against the cooler right yeah so
this is gonna be kind of like the fruits
of their labor here yeah did they study
enough did they practice enough with the
meter behind it though that's a lot of
damage on the open stage man is all
right now in control okay doctor speak
Oh race driver it's looking pretty bad
oh yeah still insisted on the slide do
it again
no because I mix up it's out of range
oh you try to do something you try to
react they're round three needed a
sidestep yeah they traded blows you
would have been able to be to be
sidestepped in time punish that Oh what
interesting could've got a launch there
yeah
shouldn't happen always that could nice
you get the Box down there with you
trying to anti-air jab of course beat it
got beat out there so our salon was
telling me just now she thought the way
to be it was - back - dead job and
that's exactly what Ken tried to do baby
back - it didn't Japanese nice yes he
hit something though because that
counter had really hurt yeah okay don't
be long side to Debray rage Pedro three
around straight from the wall here yes
do you think there's any chance that yen
would pick another character in my
opinion I hope okay don't they go saves
like 20 when he's gone to other
characters the past few months it has
not really worked out for him actually
knew they even in a dreamhack when he
lost in a righty cued up law first
it didn't work out in his favor I'd
rather you just commit the sheen I agree
it's the cast he's most comfortable with
right now and that's what he's doing
yeah sticking it to his guns there's a
fight you could hear the Japanese crowd
and cheering on again right now yeah
yeah look we have so much regional
representation here this tournament plus
the fan clubs that - it's awesome
how - the story of this year is long on
the diversity how many people have been
uh around the world that's what Jim
should play it and [ __ ] - lets get a
second batch right off the back
Hammerhead do you think it's extra
damage afterwards oh this is one game
have to take advantage when there's no
meter the risk is significantly lower on
Akuma side yeah yeah you want to start
off the strong lead here that way Akula
has to work his way up and really have
to excuse that Peter Carey at the wall
double scorpion finisher - that's the
first round on the boy hep again fight
they needed that for sure big the mental
breaker threading the needle here where
you going oh but he's in a bad position
now he's gonna have to be careful this
could hurt and then adjustment here what
does he do he keeps up there goes for a
mix-up fifty-fifty
she's keeping there he's gonna have to
be careful though nice slide I like it
takes damage there Oh brick in the back
ends your alley
yeah breaking his ankles here beautiful
basic oh my god for two from down the
Sharpshooter uppercut that Sonny does
man at the wall double scorpion finish
from minus 50% just like that again
Michael step right guard die stop what
I'm gonna see that before but probably
happens yeah he definitely hasn't seen
that before like can we turn away free
where'd he go she's not red chips
is he gonna switch he is thinking right
now he is trying to figure out what he's
gonna be doing here is you're gonna do
it I don't think he should yes you have
to go to Swiss the stage two if you pick
a different card see how regular yeah
it's interesting to see just what was he
thinking when a problem Brian he is
going to Brian you're saying he's
switching his buzz well yep yeah making
sure it sticks working let the Akuma get
you one game and then just bet it all on
Brian in the in a game three I think
it's how much Brian has he has he been
playing that's the question that I feel
like he might be inspired me was just
over in Pakistan using Brian over there
yeah you never know and you know another
level to that too right when lo ha I
went to Dubai or last month yeah you
know we were there yeah something that
lohi talked about was he felt like there
was not that much shaking representation
in Pakistan right yeah history yeah not
many people I mean Khan was gonna was
using it for a while but you went up
straight back to these you know so I
think we're gonna have a change we have
to go to brandish aid yeah they
definitely have to got a random stage
yeah some more content yeah yeah by
years locked in with Brian here so it's
really bryon versus G for the final
match that yeah I don't know what do you
guys think about that
that change yeah well the thing is like
if you you you have a choice right you
pick character or you pick stage right
oh you cannot do both you can't do both
that's too much advantage right it's
like you you you pick the wall stage and
then you also pick the character but
yeah Brian the the pick very interesting
thing I haven't seen his run for a while
man been rocking Akuma he's been really
well with the people as well I would
like to see him just stick with Akuma
and trying to make the adaptation but
yeah I was gonna ask you know how do you
how do you do you feel he should have
stuck to Cooper I think you should have
because I first much was an indication
that you can't do it right but the
second match was like get figured it out
yeah and you know the interesting thing
that I saw in Pakistan which I haven't
seen anywhere else when I was there for
the default a crack-up is when people
lose even if it's a blow up
no go straight realize they won't change
their you take time to think straight
rematch and then they would often get a
three-round combine themselves okay so
bucks on these are very generally quite
fast paced but you know bilal is more
internationally travel I guess he's kind
of got the customs of off of more
international play stars gotcha yeah but
here we go they're gonna go now to state
select yeah Brian this is Shaheen yeah
they're gonna have to pick random as
well yes
and this is gonna be the final match
here at least between these two let's
see how they stick well there we go
trying to book what goes of it with the
cereal get anyway it's a it's what are
the odds of that happening 5050 yeah all
right
at least you didn't have to do with
Pakistani is doing in-game button checks
like talk to you good old every single
batch man in packs items everyone oh
yeah this character match up to both of
these characters have really in like
rains and one rains - really damaging
counter hit options right Bryan in
particular a lot of counter hit launch
options yeah Shaheen is gonna have of
course the third of magic for down three
in the sneak stands to be able to
continue pressure from there I want to
see how Jen is able to kind of navigate
that minefield range dresser Brian is
threatening that slide yeah well I'll go
one of those fully functioning Brian
fury players he got everything he could
do you can do it all so let's see what
are you utilizing Oh what for the
talkback for there I love that I saw the
four for one for the would punish that's
something like more crackers don't use
actually but it's working as best tool
pitching security dam chapter yeah
people don't know but the Adept ornament
where our salon beat me first mo Eugene
law was in witness finals of that water
which Chanel it okay with Brian so he's
actually definitely have it has a very
strong
I chopped the Chinese definite yeah
obviously you can see it again very
confident in this matchup as well
yeah that's four rounds straight there
forget now fight bill on Easter break
the momentum if you can I mean in Japan
the boys at table right players too
it's able to catch it okay Kara that
time Jeff here comes off step three plus
four yes people support would be a very
useful move in this matchup especially
when you trying to threaten that
slightly up keep them out then go there
we go
bulky cannon once again cashing out a
lot of damage just run off those two
options displace assignment oh my rage
and slaw so tense
let's see what he does with it get them
back to the wall talked about lastly
this PC is you're standing there to
throw broken and be long edge now trying
to advance I catch them with the Vulcan
cannon it's so confident and just using
that will keep that end before the end
you just stood there waiting for an
opportunity to throw it out
fishes for that count here now who
almost got the way punished on the down
for two it's very very big recovery you
have to be able to stop that offensive
pressure there
Oh - yeah sorry open him up here he has
a good opportunity might be able to get
the kill oh you probably wasn't prepared
to hit it good break that point for blah
what a turnaround we thought I thought
he was gonna lose that round
that means such a huge comeback there
off the time you've seen more than you
unlock that with Jimmy man when you get
Brian at the wall dangerous stuff let up
it's the highway to the dangerzone you
gotta be careful
I mean Wayne's downpour once again right
now we get a dozen fight off on her own
there's something about this game it's
rape brush its brake nice tore the cross
bottle up here let see what he does
picks up City Oh tried it well he
definitely fell furred there just didn't
get to catch on the shut up yeah
no back down the lags get in trouble
I've involved takes her over cat it
moves into top hate on the winner side
close match back and forth the law with
the correct choice they're going bright
have very Frankenstein paid off mmm-hmm
man what I said very very good said man
I like I said man below you know he has
been rocking Brian and you know in so
many tournaments when I first saw him he
was getting you know top threes
consistently with Brian so people might
think that all he just he's just good
but I'm winning because of a cream I
know this guy can play you've seen the
right here did the brother furtively
that means we're gonna get John ding
look feel all in the winner of our next
match
kagemaru versus MVP DHD peco's japan
burster pan dr. mean that's gonna be
winners top eight side TECO's actually
made a pretty far last year at the LCQ
if you guys remember that he was the one
that played against time back on the
stage this time Katja maru's King to
come back you never know very very
treatment that master cup five-match
comeback ocv now is uh and this is just
fine as news they casuals man both these
guys played shows all the time so so
what's the history with these to you
when they do play each other like who
usually comes out toward you quite
usually mix because peco's has actually
been running so many different
characters recently really like yeah
target Marvin pretty much loyal to Josie
at this point sevens likes Bennett yeah
I would say at his strongest you know
peco's in Tekken 6 take Tekken 6 BR he
was dominating Japan with his Bob yes
veteran Bob player obviously we all know
he can use Bob but I mean I'm right now
he's using geese right I mean ironically
we know kagemaru from that master Cup
performance a couple years ago yeah
necklace was the original version of
that right with Bob he pulled off the
reversal CP before anybody else did yeah
man crazy stuff yet both these guys were
playing so well today
who saw echoes actually said kudos at
loser bracket earlier in Wow
few tens of course out of the 21 as well
but lost to I think so the big question
mark that I'm gonna hammer this matchup
is peco's character selection Russell so
I mean I've only really been seen him
play piece but what else has he been
playing what is it juicy stone geese
Katerina Bop of course I'll let you rip
it's a big question mark it'll be going
on character selection he's King to for
a while yeah yeah King as well before
Bob came out before geese came even even
this year internment he's using easiest
King at least once definitely is king
also has a jacket rip look at that
update oh my god what wow that's crazy
damn tell the people go ahead so I
musician has just eliminated here are
two to one very very interesting stuff
there so Korea doing bits hey at the LCQ
he ran out with the tournament were
these Korean guys come from they're so
good
Korea to do Pakistan my side although
let me drink oh man crazy by musicians
been having a fantastically lost job
being a little bit earlier but now
eliminating here and they lose the side
of thing he's still never president
threatened lose your side it doesn't
matter what side you're on as long as
you get to the finals a win this
tournament right that's all about first
place yeah it's only there's only one
spot yeah you're not getting like twt
point for top eight or something you
know what I'll give them some point no
job that means that birdie in my
musician are gonna be in loser side what
happened to Dubai did it all happen
impulse if I'm not mistaken to him okay
so a run back I mean you know it could
definitely happen we know we saw a last
shake your loved that he won the LCD
from two losses IRA double put him in
loses you came before it that month so
you know those guys in losses right now
definitely have a have a shout to
witness
right now we have the winners side we've
got kagemaru from Japan going to pick
its peco's wait so out of the regions we
have left that are in this it's it's
it's Asia it's mostly Korea Japan accent
Philippines yes that's it right I'm
sorry
yeah I didn't say that that was ripped
up did anyone see what cartoon shows
we'll see we'll see all right anyways
we're gonna get started with this
matchup again this is for winners hi top
eight oh boy
battle is two Japanese players okay so
Peck was going with geese and we have
kagemaru with Josie keep it as simple
mmm the thing with kagemaru is momentum
the student and when Anna's peak
performances is riding waves of momentum
he's had an incredible performance
already today going into this set man
you got to show me something let's go
yeah focus
fight
Echo's ten sites have left all day you
see peco's trying to get into the range
zero range one be able to plot that jab
and down for one pressure yeah one thing
I was saying about geese now is I feel
this a lot more entertained it to what
because of its meter you have to manage
the beast I could just throw out winning
any whenever you like and I think Pekka
food is a really good example of how to
manage meats are properly that's a great
point
I get more with a good block and begin
this corner positioning here with a good
lie fleet as well and Peck with his side
stuff all the way around turns it around
at tomorrow's back what a good side
switch there we get the ball up there
one for the downpours old by that
buddy's gonna get the stud there yeah
look at this corner position here with a
good time winding down gets out of that
oh but that counts a hit this you should
be the first round yeah he's done nice
sidewall doesn't matter you so figure it
out yeah we were just talking about this
earlier how many counter hit low get up
kicks up we had every today that's big
gets the fault with the four three let's
see what he does he should be able to
get the wall here the delay goes for
some extra damage yeah good sidestep
that front pack cross all he's gonna get
the bottle up here extra damage and see
what he does
oh this is gonna kill oh it should have
killed if he landed back that was a big
opportunity but it just something
fortunate for him still able to close it
out flying it up around we get peco's
hasn't used a single Barbie I used
building up like I said he wants to
build up that means you say Wendy how
are you saving for the next match
something oh there you go
you should get the break here
nice Sun nothing yet put a coke line at
75% just like that yeah good option
different kagemaru going for the spring
kick stopping the momentum also getting
away from the wall which is very
important touch those toes it makes up
just jab pressure and taking those
downpours as well it's so interesting
how he stayed in such a close range mr.
Josey he doesn't want to let Josie you
get a mid range to start going look for
those crowd - mix up the stick stay at
his face jab away sighs hit 3041 to
smother ya giving him no room to really
try any mix up other than a jab yeah
sighs oh look at that lady just staying
in the optimal range but this time
getting hit by the magic more
yes I'm getting it one more time you
should get to get there quick three hit
straight to follow up what's to get a
new sound for three all right look at
that final round here that's why you
punish a parry it's that man fun I'll be
breaking these for asthma but look at
the look at the meter here that peco's
house go get up man he's gonna have to
use it use it or lose it no oh boy oh
babe I don't even have a chance
oh that would have been in oh man did
not bid for that trade oh here we go
this could be big topic yeah cuz he has
the range art as well Oh drop the car
for three closing it out look at that
looked really good man kagemaru yeah
maybe he had an opportunity that he had
two balls of media so he could have got
a big big combo there but dropped him I
didn't get the - talk tomorrow takes
full advantage with the first match is
it gonna stick with you sir is it gonna
stay with you so much i I think you will
I think you will he's gonna think about
it he'll be like you know what I could
have done it I just didn't use my meter
that's true yeah was just not even the
opportunity be able to cue it up right I
thought towards the enemy's gonna be
just half mashing on back three looking
for a manual bag spoke but he got the
second to just drop the couple yeah so
he's gonna stick to it yes like when
they do at this point yeah
now we're gonna see peco's get three
perfect to the road swish around you've
got what much last year
I wouldn't wish that on anybody that's
my curse on your family curse on your
house babies are gonna go into the
matchup let's see how this one's gonna
play on kagemaru versus Peck was
kagemaru up 1-0 right now on ashore too
as well you know hope it easy yeah this
does this doesn't hurt him as much now
in this season right because a teacher
wins on the property that has miss
Campos he imprinted stage really doesn't
matter this do bleeds he gets them no
matter what yeah FPS meter he's gonna
get that damage if he has range he's
gonna get some real damage
sure I really like what they've done to
keep certain species right off the bat -
makes a fart coming out of kagemaru well
he knows that peco's doesn't have meat
so that's minus 14 could have got full
note with me to buy you know his bottles
go for it let's float hearing good
here's the run-up what you gonna do okay
another hockey March getting out ho the
thing is you know when they need to play
in the close range OPEC lesense come out
on top for both of them for most of the
matchup yeah so car Kumar's gonna have
to kind of figure out a way to get out
of that range or yeah at least pekus is
off the ball range by the range of that
doubt dreamer its OPEC costs on the
court here whose second game has a
Barbie get to work with as well and get
the whip punished it's just the strength
of his fundamentals being able to use
the jab the down Ford one is to really
in great a story for himself cause I
mean you know he's not going for big
lows or anything yeah he's just
controlling the space with the jab in
the side steps I guess can't do that
right geez kids play like any Keys could
have always played just a conventional
Tech it has a very good afford one with
folks in general the newts is just a
little cherry on top he's caused the
building to is gonna have to be very
careful because if he does get a two
round lead and that meter it's gonna be
very very tough for Kamara huh he's
gonna have to get a triple perfect
follow up here gets the three-piece
afterwards Amaro on the board your game
to perfect spacing and anticipation just
pull the trigger on it gets a slice get
like a full cup one down the other - 50
percent doesn't matter is so draining
it's a wall right oh yeah if you try to
like watch it imagine if he's doing yeah
oh my gosh
round 4 there we go water out the way
from evening off the set one notch
apiece
can you do it here try them now the
response here
nice gets a big cat agree that's gonna
be huge three three four bulbous to
follow up and it gets a slide oh man
flashbacks
there we go final round game to let
anybody think his bottom left corner
your screen look at that horse
he had meet her last time - he has to
use it that's the big that's a man I
don't think a key was gonna let if he
doesn't want him to he's taking his face
here but he's gonna have to be careful
because you know feckless is beginning a
lot of mileage other than sliced up he's
gonna sidestepping back to the punish
you just wants to get a ring that's all
he wants what we're here oh he's gonna
go for the combo that is the second time
in the cell we've seen him joke
after getting the screws yeah he saves
up all this meter right he keeps on
saving up he never practice I'm good I'm
good at that go stayin alive there
clutching the out stayin for even up a
little now right that's mu that's
something about Pettis is DS that's kind
of like it kind of puts him under the
radar right we get so distracted with
watching with players like Chickering
right we're so optimized for every hit
yeah I mean peco's has has not been that
much in terms of combos in the execution
but in terms of scrambles neutral he's
really uh he's had good success this
year but he is not really that's not why
we watch him right yeah I mean I think
last year's summer jam or something and
you know he'll and all his columns on me
there he wasn't concerned at all so it
might be some nerves no real offenders
gotta clear against yeah but he also
plays multiple games it's not just
Tekken you know place a lot of games
plays everything so stick it in here and
finish your game number three is it man
this is gonna decide who's gonna be that
last message back to the winner side of
top eight it's a gonna be Petco's or
Corcovado hope he comes out here from
kagemaru you saw
hey he's in the air for like 400 Brady
no blood didn't make some just Jeffries
didn't slide and low they're now turning
up the aggression you're whoa do you
want supply two ready to get the powers
of the meeting presses buttons a good
counting upon the switch three gets the
beam picks up a question from Holly's
ago in it what did we say earlier
momentum player right when he starts to
smell that blood he starts going okay
now your defenses crumbling a little bit
you start to get a little bit nervous
yes and we saw that last much as well he
was super aggressive when he didn't have
any meat sir have you got a cat it still
hasn't filled up a bar below and he's
down trousers cream I thought it's
logged good position for Pecola see he's
out of his mind right now that was a
good hit there from necklace of course
but kagemaru hits on that point almost
stop right now he's gonna go for a mix
up let's see what he does - ah nice that
would have been a crazy comeback they're
starting to swing now in these fantastic
suits that back that last round again
hey they might do that one thing again
all over the place it's in the stars
right oh man it's under guards
what's he got he just needs that one
appreciate that one with Punisher launch
oh he had to sandy - but unable to
convert to Kabul damage
I wish they were more mindful of a
commentator to do it in tune with the
beat a Twitter side
and he's definitely one of the players
that we you know we were looking at the
plays a weird making our decision of who
we thought a new charger a lot of us
overlook kagemaru but here is winner
sided topic yes and we've got another
update so octave but has eliminated
mogul from the tournament did a lot of
work to yeah yeah he was one of my picks
actually to to get quite far this
morning but he's been playing really
well in Korea so yeah but unfortunately
I mean it was the combination of
character kagemaru and mogul that
removed one of the favorites to win this
event right yeah John no longer in this
bracket as a result of them the T [ __ ]
we the one moving on and loser side Wow
how many Pakistan players we have left
in the tournament I think we've got a
Sonali we got belong and see so yeah
that's the maybe three there might be I
don't know yeah sick three I think
that's about right
and it's just below on the winter side
of things yes yeah crazy but like we
said my last year it was it was from
someone from the looser side actually
want the whole tour of a solenoid
yeah but the most dramatic fashion is
possible to man yeah it was Seiko say
all right guys we will be back with some
more Tekken 7 action live from the TW
LCQ and I just can't wait we'll be back
in a bit